so as a man I'm obviously not a man what
is it that meant value in a woman
clearly it's very different but my ID my
thought process is I want to be able to
have traveled be open-minded because if
you're traditional man I'm assuming you
want to have a family you want to have
kids don't you want to be with a woman
that is worldly educated well-traveled
can bring something to the table rather
than somebody that has absolutely no
idea about anything in life and really
can't contribute anything outside of
just being a woman um sorry yeah no
that's a simple answer isn't it yeah no
no we don't want that at all okay
there's on one key point there
um the the idea of being well traveled
is a giant red flag for most people
because typically
when a woman if you if I look at a
woman's Instagram page and I see
pictures of her on a private jet on a
yacht in multiple different fancy
locations she's a Mykonos here she's in
Paris she's in Dubai she's in New York
my immediate assumption is this woman is
a hoe yeah I do have already
automatically no no it's not probably
uh yeah the women that are traveling
everywhere are going and living a
luxurious lifestyle I'm assuming that
I'm working all over Europe
I mean the example I just gave is always
is clearly a woman who's been flown out
by a man
and probably probably because it's
different cities probably different
exactly he's trying to tell you what he
wants and you're trying to tell him
that's not
I'm not telling you this month I'm
trying to honest
oh apparently I don't want that oh no no
I think it's like to guys most girls
that travel around from City to city
they're sleeping around so it's like if
it walks like a duck quacks like a duck
how is he supposed to know that it's not
a duck especially when women lie then
you have a conversation with a person
that's why I wasn't neglecting I wasn't
saying that what he's saying was wrong
my question was why have you
automatically assumed that that is the
case because it's there's experience
judgmental attitude this is going on
it's literally just pattern recognition
if I see if I see a guy okay if I'm
going on a date with a guy yeah and he
walks like a bum talks like a bum he
doesn't seem to have a job am I
judgmental for thinking this man might
be a bum and then he says you know what
I'm a millionaire babe and I'm just like
you know I don't think you believe me
what if with you going and pairing up
with this man if he's got something else
too he's got beautiful characteristics
if he's got something in his spirit that
you're like oh my gosh he's amazing what
if you added value to him and you
brought him I am just I'm not look I
come from a hard-working family like a
word German okay
and and it's a tag
um
but but it's like no that just wouldn't
work with my family so if he's a bum now
and that's okay too but I think that you
know as
no job not even like a sorry I thought
individuals go on like we've all got our
different things that we look for right
like if you look for in a woman someone
to have that clean slay somebody that's
going to be at home raise the kids
that's okay a lot of my male friends of
which I have so many who are like family
to me they're like my brothers like
honestly like my brother red flag
is the thing like these people are
people who I love so much and their
opinions on all of this this whole
movement is that you're only valuing
people based off of real skin deep stuff
which is really sad for Humanity but
that's what everyone's selling these
days yeah but women-based men off skin
deep I don't and a lot of times
how many it like you saying just as a
hypothetical right you're saying oh I
need to I need to date a woman who has
been flown out to all corners of the
Earth by a bunch of different men is
like me saying to you you have a guy
who's five foot one you have to but we
are just you have no choice about this
you have to let it goes five foot one
irrespective of anything else no it
isn't the whole point of this
conversation about modern day yes women
and my theory is is like if we were
still back in the day where my mum was
going out and doing everything and I
could stay at home that's a lovely
different story that's not the case why
do you think why do you think that's not
the case with her now okay now we're
gonna generalize because I've never met
a man never there said I'm happy for you
to do that I will take the lead here and
I will provide everything and you can
stay at home
that just means you can't get the guys
that do that
it's based off of women's choices
because there's plenty of men
and your environment there's plenty of
men that want to provide for their girls
there's plenty of guys that want to do
it I'm not saying that they're on I'm
just saying in I I live in London you
live in London yeah that's I've not come
across that it's not typical it might be
fishing in the wrong Pond then okay
maybe but again if we're if the whole
conversation has been generalized that's
the generalized thing about modern day
dating so I understand when she's saying
as in my 20s I've had to go out and work
my ass off because I've never been able
to rely on a man over 18 19 20 21 did
you ever try to date an older guy like
35 about 30 yeah 35 40. not that no no
okay it would have been an option for
you 18 to 22 if you if you okay
you having a family like things that you
can't date a bum mama might let me date
a 40 year old at 18. that's my family
okay okay let's do 22. 22 to 35. I still
feel no no
based on the background and culture but
I'm saying the whole the whole point is
most women young attractive In-Shape
women which is all choices have the
option to stay at home if they go for
the right type of guy but a lot of times
when we're young we're not going for the
husbands like it's what I did
um me I'm so thankful for my mentality
because I did I was um 19 dating uh 30
year old man and it made sense because
when I was um I was already committed
from Young I was ready to make I was
already in that mindset already and a
loser I lost basically most of my
friends because of that decision so I
had to choose between being a committed
19 year old wife material or be a young
19 year old girl and going out basically
the week that I met my son's dad it was
he was that um
um that week someone I just came back
from like a vacation with like a guy
that obviously I met with a signature
and stuff so that week I met my son's
dad and
I went with my son's dad and he might
not have
um firstly asked me to go to Dubai with
him all this with him but I chose
already this is the kind of guy that I
need I don't need the guy that wants to
buy me Chanel drive me in a Range Rover
all them stuff because I know I could
just already tell it's too good to be
true you're selling something I'm buying
something I'm selling something so it's
just it's not even it didn't even start
off right but so then I just kind of cut
him off and went with um my son's dad he
wasn't my sons at the time but
um all my friends I lost a lot of
friends they were laughing at me like oh
my God you're so young you need to go
out this guy I don't think they're real
friends that's what I'm getting to they
were telling me like oh you we need to
go out why are you stuck in the house
playing while laughing at me and I was
so embarrassed but at that point it
still didn't I was just strong you know
what I don't think they weren't laughing
at you because they they were looking
down on you they were laughing at you
because they were jealous of your ass
I don't even know the story
that's why that's why I'm so proud to
say this that I chose him and um yeah
everyone's just like looking at us odd
like why are you guys so in love in the
relationship you've left all your
friends now you we create we started
creating our own world and Empire from
then on even though we weren't perfect
on the right places but it was the right
time that's why I always say to people
everything is the time frame it's not
after you've traveled it's not after
you've done the it's the right time but
the friends that were laughing at me
that didn't go out with every single
time they were left with them men that
had Range Rovers and stuff with like a
kid or two here they don't know whether
dad is here they're not acknowledging
their kids although me and my sons that
we had ups and down he never he never
left my side he never left my son's dad
my son's side so now I'm laughing at
them and at the time that you could have
spent focusing on the right guys you
focused on lifestyle well and but look
at the lifestyle it gave you and and the
whole point is we all have choices we
might have been given the wrong
information and made bad choices based
on the information we had at the time
and you can't change it now but it's
like at the end of the day every we all
know right from any any young attractive
woman has option to get married